this is the scariest thing I've ever
ever been through in my life that's pink
opening up about her battle with the
coronavirus during an emotional
interview with Ellen DeGeneres on
Thursday you can't help her watch the
news every day and I'm like oh my god
like Wow all the crazy stuff I did like
this is it face pink explained that she
and her three-year-old son Jamison
contracted the virus in mid-march
Jamison got sick first but she was quick
to follow a certain point maybe around
March 18th March 19th March 20th when
his fever was staying and going up I
woke up in the middle of the night and
couldn't breathe
and what's extra scary is that pink says
she's had asthma for a full life I mean
it might an abuser for the first time in
30 years and I have this inhaler that I
use a rescue inhaler and I couldn't
function without it and that's when I
started to get really scared
that's when pink had to fight back tears
talking about her baby boy and his
symptoms you know at one point when he
started throwing up and saying that he
had chest pains and then it hurt to
breathe that's the point where you just
kind of like okay are we going to the
hospital like what are we doing right
now because this is the scariest thing
I've ever ever been through in my life
so the two eventually got better and
thankfully Pink's eight-year-old
daughter Willow and her hubby Carey Hart
didn't get sick it's very controversial
two people that I was able to get my
hands on a test and pink addressed all
the people who were throwing shade at
her because she was able to get tested
when others can't I would say two things
to that I would say you should be angry
that I can get a test and you can't but
being angry at me is not going to help
anything it's not gonna solve the issue
of the fact that you can't get your
hands on a test you should be angry
about that and we should work together
to try and change that and number two
tell me anybody with a sick
three-year-old that if they could get
their hands on a test wouldn't take it
and if they say that I'm calling both
you